okay there's the flea all the time
because you absolutely want to listening
online we're going to get started and
the morning session thing is going to be
talking about some more applied problems
on what we've seen so far press these
speakers thank you know what kind of
title to give so I gave a title which
sounded more provocative you know but it
really what we're trying to achieve is
we're trying to do marginalization and
I'll explain that's the same thing as
doing you know in matrix inversion
here's the matrix inversion but only for
a few variables okay so I'd like to
thank the organizers for inviting me and
I was not sure what to expect from this
so if I can explain to you what the
problem is and if I can get some
feedback that would be great okay so as
I said I'm wasn't quite sure what the
connection is between the problems we
are solving and the problems of this
conference but we are also trying to do
stochastic linear algebra problems so
there is some connection there so let me
start by talking about the problem
itself
I'll define a more specific problem in
the context of least squares on the next
slide but let me first start telling
about what we try to do when we try to
do data analysis we have a lot of latent
variables so these are the variables
that create an event or events that we'd
like to analyze in our context I know
cosmologists so I try to do try to study
the universe I observe the galaxies but
the galaxies are not the galaxy
positions for example are not
necessarily something we care about we
care about more about their the hyper
parameters that created that
distribution okay so there's a whole
bunch of latent variables that are for
which we know their prior solution in
fact it's it's a multivariate Gaussian
and but what we would like to learn is
what those observations like galaxies
positions
tell us about the underlying purpose of
the universe
all right I'll explain more what I mean
by this so we care about the
hyperparameters we care about what
determines these latent variables not
the latent variables themselves so that
means in a pickle
statistical inference problem you would
marginalize over these latent variables
the first question is do we really need
to marginalize can we just maximize the
maximum likelihood estimation of all the
variables at once and and just go go
away with that the answer is yes we need
to marginalize you can get really wrong
answers if you just try to marginalize
latent variables and their high
performance at once okay into this but
it's well known that Maximizer estimator
is biased even in the asymptotic limit
if you have same number of variables of
observations there's a famous name of
Scott problem for example and so this is
the same statement here you can get
biased results if you don't do
marginalization okay so how does this
relate to the linear algebra well in
linear algebra for example imagine that
we had a full rank Hessian for all of
these variables both the variables yes
yes I was going to say imagine that we
have the Hessian of all of these
variables both the latent variables and
the parameters we're trying to estimate
so this would be second derivative
information about against the latent
variables and against the parameters let
me get to that on these two slides it's
gonna be least square yeah so for now
let's just assume that we have a hessian
then if you want to marginalize over the
these latent variables what we would do
we would invert the hessian we take the
rows and columns that correspond to this
to the parameter we care about and we
would get rid of everything else right
and then if necessary we invert it again
to get the
matrix out of out of the covariance
matrix all right so that's the procedure
in low dimensions the problem is that in
high dimensions this doesn't work this
process scales as an Ncube as soon as n
is more than I don't know hundred
thousand maybe these days this is not
possible anymore to do ok so let me just
you know this is trivial and assume
you've all seen this but let me just you
know go through this again
if we have to do merchants ation in 2d
imagine you have a 2d Hessian this would
be these coefficients here I wrote them
as an inverse of the covariance matrix
because that's what Hessian is alright
but these are you think of this as being
coefficients you want to marginalize
over 100 to get the posterior just for
the second variable then what you know
if you do this completion of squares you
know you add probably you've seen all
this before but anyway you are at
something you complete the square you
the then the integral over a in this
case and you're left with something
which is inverse of these 2 by 2 matrix
and then you just take the look the
element that corresponds to the variable
that you care about okay so this is this
is the inversion right matrix ok so
let's move on so what is that we are how
do we get the Hessian what is our
problem we try to solve the you know the
regular eyes least square problem you
have some data in our case let's say
galaxy positions in the sky we have some
model to predict this data this model
depends on a bunch of latent variables
which are called little s all right the
data are noisy so there's some noise
matrix in principle although you know we
can assume that agonal and just just a
multiplier times the identity in the
simplest case and we can assume for the
simplicity that noise is Gaussian and we
can write down the permutation the noise
just as a multi
very OCD which is just data - the model
as I said I'm sure these latent
variables here s and we often know their
prior in fact we in the context of the
studies that we care about the prior is
really what we care about we don't care
about the latent variables themselves we
care about what their power is so we
care about their power spectrum alright
so that means they're these latent
variables are distributed as a
multivariate Gaussian and in its best if
one can find the prior where this
expression is diagonal where this matrix
here is SSA agonal in our case for
example this matrix is diagonal in
Fourier space okay so now what we have
is that the joint probability bution is
the product of the two and the problem
is that we have you know we have two
matrices why is the agonal in one space
in congregation space or real space and
the other one is diagonal in Fourier
space so when you put the two together
you get basically announced parse full
rank matrix that is non sparse in any
basis it's not sparse in any basis okay
so you cannot easily do the matrix
inversion so for example if i linearize
this problem if I say F of s is just
some matrix times s then the covariance
matrix of the data one can show is just
given by this expression in this
expression you see we have to be able to
compute the determinant of the
covariance matrix and inverse of the
matrix grants matrix is this thing here
and as I said it's full rank and
typically cannot be diagonalized
in any simple basis so we don't know how
to do matrix inversion or determinant if
the dimensionality of the data is very
large
there's not this expression in the
exponential better this is this is a X
seen this was X yeah in my language
isn't the X transpose this is a number
right yeah yeah X transpose inverse you
just need to be able to compute the
exponential fast yes within a problem
you need to be able to try C inverse to
back right that's what you mean yeah
yeah it's like in fact if I did usually
you know don't worry so much about this
term this term actually turns out that
we don't need to know that much but this
is the hard term the determinant is a
hard number of data in this context
number of data then I'll translate it
later into a number of latent variables
both of both the data and latent
variables can be in millions in fact the
latent variables that we plan to work
with it's 10 to the 10th that's why I
had this 10 to the 10 in my so you're
trying to optimize the related values
well I don't care about latent variables
I care about the the proper parameters
in this case their power spectrum for
example this s this power tracking
because I said this is they're going for
your info your basis yes continues
function yeah I mean it is example our
show I'll have 30 or 40 something s in
for your space is diagonal matrix yes
sorry yes yes it's a power spectrum and
do you know anything about the structure
of C is it strongly diary dominant so
that you could
no no that's because the data as soon as
you go into the into impartial data you
have gaps and holes you have fine a
finite survey then C is not diagonal
dominant it's very full ranking you
don't know much about it I mean you know
something about it I guess if you have
perfect data yes it would be diagonally
for inference in in configuration space
in real space it's definitely not a
aerial dominant because the correlations
between the data points on all scales
basically this point on the sky is
calling with that point on the sky you
know that's what inflationary theory
does for you everything is correlated in
our universe that's great because
there's a lot of information there but
it makes the problem much harder the
condition number of the matrix is also
horrible often it's very large
okay so let's move on so here I have
linearized this thing just just for you
to get some intuition but the problem we
are working on is actually we are trying
to do this nonlinear volution actually
so this f of s you can think of it as a
fully full nonlinear evolution of the
universe from its initial conditions
which are you know this Gaussian latent
variable fluctuations all the way to
very nonlinear a picture of galaxies in
the sky okay I'll show an example later
this the point is this is a fully
nonlinear evolution we run partial
differential equations with n body
simulation as I said we often work with
10 to the 10 latent variables and return
particles we say it's an n body
simulation and this is extremely
expensive computer all right so the
point I'm trying to make is we're
dealing with with the situation where
likelihood evaluation for each
configuration of latent variables is
extremely explained expensive to to
evaluate you're talking about tens of
hours for single evaluation and we want
to I don't know sample or get some kind
of solution
which corresponds to the actual data in
the sky all right that's that's the
difficulty ok we'll assume that we have
gradients access to the gradients of F
respect to all variables and parameters
so this is an PDE
system so we have developed back
propagation algorithms to get the
gradients respect to everything
everything means all those 10 to the 10
parameters ok here my collaborators on
this so the first question is can we do
this brute force by just sampling with
MCMC now if you if you try to sample
with the metropolis algorithm which
doesn't even have a gradient access then
you're kind of its kind of hopeless you
have curse of dimensionality you know it
just has no way to find where to go to
find this 10 to the 10 solutions and to
sound sample done properly you can do
better if you try with remote only Monte
Carlo
where the gradient is available but
still even in this case people who have
tried this fine that it takes thousands
of likely declarations to get a single
independent sample okay because the
samples are very correlated in the
context of agency so moreover MCM scene
high noise regime converges very slowly
on hyper parameters that's just due to
the fact that well MCMC sampling from
some kind of through posterior and it's
kind of hard to tell for the sampler
what's what's real and what's fake
because he has to put in fake stuff to
make up for what we don't know about
okay okay so we don't think one we can
do this with MC MC what about
optimization with gradients let's try
that so this is what I will be talking
about there's a carrot of course since
this is nonlinear evolution we are
talking about non convex optimization so
there's no guarantee that whatever we
find is the global minimum but
nevertheless I'll show you know we get
actually very good results so we think
we are probably close to well I mean in
the correct thing to do would be to find
all of the minima and then average them
with a proper important sampling weights
okay
the approximation we're making here is
that we are you know we're going to be
descending as far as we can and we
declared that to be the deepest minimum
so that we ignore everything else right
that's the approximation we are making
here if you work in this kind of high
very high dimensions there's really not
much you can do there's no way to you
know there's just no way to find it
there's if there's another minimum which
is deeper especially if it's if you have
to go across the hill to get there
but you can get stuck at the stationary
point yeah well yeah right and of course
we try to use those those methods yeah
we try stochastic stuff we try you know
I should say this is God this is least
square problem
so in these square problems usually
don't actually get stuck on cell points
okay so let's first ask ourselves how do
we find the best latent variables all
right so we try to well if all the
gradient let's take a log of that
posterior that I wrote down there it's
essentially just a regularized
chi-square now I have the data and then
you have the prior here the L to a
regularizer and you take a gradient of
this stuff and you know if you take a
second derivative then you also have the
Hessian we never evaluate this as I said
because this would be a 10 to the 10
square matrix but in principle at least
as a conceptual Hanser matrix there and
you see now I've converted this Hessian
from data to the to the latent variables
so it's actually inverse of this an
inverse of this and you know again if we
work with 10 to the 10 latent variable
then we're talking about this matrix
would be 10 to the 10 square okay so we
don't actually use Newton's method we
use quasi Newton methods or we use
actually we do use actually a stock
Contra gradient method which is you know
actually second-order because we have
developed also the dot product between
the Gauss Newton version of the Hessian
times to the gradient so that's that's
how we approach this we're descending
slowly in this very high dimensions
until we find something all right
until we hit the minimum and I'm really
clear that to be our global minimum and
we then try to ask now that we are here
what do we do with it how do we get the
hyper parameters
okay so as I mentioned before we do have
access to the totality gradients of both
the latent variables and the hyper
parameters let's call these hyper
parameters I don't see or something of
that so what we want is basically get
the gradient and the Hessian of these
hyper parameters marginalized over all
the latent variables alright so again as
I mentioned before you know one solution
would be with the linear algebra we
would have to therefore invert this very
large matrix and that's just not
possible so what can we do what
advantage here compared to the general
problem is that we do have actually a
generative model to create these samples
here so whenever we have basic approach
the graphical model so we can model from
the latent variables all the way to the
data then we can do this now does this
help and the answer is it does help
because and let's look at this in the
context of sampling let's try to replace
now this marginalization with the
statement well we can just exampling
averages whatever I need at this I think
a gradient of this marginalized log
posterior okay what is marginal ah
posterior it's we take a grading respect
to the integral over these latent
variables I can propagate this integral
so I can write this probability remember
that I had this loss function in a
previous slide that's just minus log
probability so I can rewrite this as you
know this integral of PS e to the minus
L if I plug the gradient on this then I
see you see I can get a gradient on the
loss function but it's really average
over the full prevalence efficient of
the latent variables so you can think of
this as the gradient average over all
the samples of the latent variables you
can do something similar with the
Hessian now you have to take second
derivative you take another derivative
this and let me just show you final
result the first part of the answer is
it is expected you just get a second
derivative of the loss function
sample overall the latent variables so
think of this as the partial derivative
part if this were if the hyper
parameters were not correlated with the
latent variables this would be all we
need
but unfortunately they are correlated
and so now we get the term when you see
it comes with a minus sign and just you
know the term which actually takes the
gradient and square the gradient
literally and then you take the average
of this look at what about this look
like in the context of just two-by-two
matrix you know again the same context
I've shown you before we can take the
gradient respect to the first variable
it's and think of it if you have a two
by two matrix you know you have this
same this Hessian that I had before
Sigma inverse 1 1 Sigma inverse 1 2 so
this is the gradient the second
derivative but now we need to average
this over this term over z2 for example
and if we do this then this term here
actually gives us this and the bottom
line is when we evaluate this expression
here we get exactly what we want which
is the inverse of the matrix of the
Hessian matrix and then component 4 for
that element that we care about all
right so this procedure here the
sampling procedure gives you the inverse
of the marginalized sorry gives you the
cut the row and column of the inverse of
the covariance matrix sorry right so it
gives you what you want that's good and
the price you pay is that you have to do
the sampling averages so well
unfortunately this okay well before I
get to how how will we do this so the
price we pay is we have to sample now
with a sample from the from the
posterior can we do this well we cannot
directly sample from the posterior
because again even if we had full
Hessian we don't know how to diagonalize
or all right let's do cholesky
decomposition to actually be able to
draw the samples is the same
problems before if we are in you know 10
to 10 dimensions then we cannot get the
cholesky decomposition of the very large
matrix so we cannot directly sample from
from from the Hessian now we can of
course go back and do the MCMC approach
and maybe just evaluate a few samples
and I argued before that this is still
very expensive you know it takes few
thousand steps to get a single
independent sample so so maybe this
approach works but it seem very
promising alternative is we just make an
approximation to the posteriors in the
following way
we already had this map solution the
maximum possible solution of the latent
variables we can run a simulation draw
from insulation we know exactly what we
have put in so we know the true value we
can run the map approximation to this
simulation we get map values for this
simulation and then we add this
difference here to our map of the data
the idea is that this will be we're kind
of approximating the posterior
distribution of the data by by adding
this difference between what the
simulation would do and what the true
answer in summation is so think about it
if you determine the if map determines
the parameter well then this difference
will be very small okay if if the data
are not constraining very well the
latent variables then latent variables
go to 0 and then you know this
difference here essentially this is 0
and this is 0 and then this is just a
sample of the two value the sample of
the true value so you get correct
samples but of course this sample true
Ally is useless because it was drawn
from a simulation not from the data and
doesn't actually contain any information
about the underlying hyper parameters
okay so with dried is and this works
well we get unbiased results now the
problem here is that we will also like
to have the hessian the second matrix
the second derivative is because we
would like to give errors to our
parameters that we are estimating in
fact these parameters are often
correlated so we want to hop the full
covariance matrix provides matrix the
inverse of the Hessian matrix we're
talking about low dimensionality
you know easy to invert this so that's
not a problem however the problem is
that this term here the second term here
this marginalization term is actually
very noisy okay so let me show you an
example of the variance of if the hyper
parameter s is the parameter we care
about so this is our loss function that
I wrote we can take a gradient respect
to this let's say this s is a function
of Z so just for simplicity okay but I'm
taking derivatives respect to s
basically do I get these kind of
expressions let me not go into all the
details but I just want to point out
that this expression here the gradient
is the sum over all the data points this
term here that I mentioned before this
term that we are subtracting out is the
sum of all the data points time to sum
over all the other points so it goes as
na naaaa data point squared so this term
is very noisy all right and as a
consequence then this Hessian is very
noisy so an alternative an alternative
is to try anything marginalization we
try to do the integral over the latent
variables first and this pulls out this
Hessian again the dimension before I
wrote it here in the in the gauss newton
approximation where i drop a second
derivatives and you know it looks bad
however when you take a gradient of this
expression you get this kind of
expression you only get you get the
gradient of at the map value at the peak
of these latent variables and minus a
term which is the gradient of the log
log determinant of that matrix again
this matrix is ten to ten square matrix
you will have no chance of trying to get
this determinant between an algebra what
one can do instead one knows that this
gradient the whole gradient has to
vanish if you run a simulation and you
run assimilation with where you know the
true value of the
of the late of the hyper parameter and
generate your your latent variables with
that true value then you know that on
average this grain has to vanish because
the gradient at the correct value on
average has to be zero so that's a way
therefore to determine this term here
okay so so again I mean to do this
you're running we're on examination so
we're doing some kind of sampling but
it's a much easier form sampling okay so
and then finally how do we do the
Hessian we we have tried many different
things and we find that the best way to
do this is simply with a finite
difference well this matrix now good
question
so yes we do take advantage a lot of the
sampling noise reduction metals for
example in the context of this question
you just asked is it noisy yes it is
noisy but if you draw both let's say for
model a and pro model Zi Zi and Zi you
draw with the same random seeds then the
difference actually is not noisy so this
is one one way where you can reduce the
noise and by the way we do similar
things also to get a gradient alright so
we definitely you know this kind of
sampling reaction noise methods
definitely help a lot ok so let me show
you what we're going to try to do we try
to apply this to cosmology problem so
these are simulation we start with very
tiny fluctuations and we move forward
into the real data space today here's
another example all right we take you
know fluctuations tiny fluctuations like
in cosmic background and then we evolve
forward the model and we get this kind
of nice-looking simulations of very
nonlinear structures so these are for a
model I won't go into details and since
I'm running out of time but
let me just tell you we start with
Gaussian fluctuations here these are the
Dark Matter today you see it's very non
Gaussian it has voids and filaments and
so on and this is what the light looks
like the galaxies light you know so
galaxy line only appears where we have
the highest density peaks
so this is our generative model
basically and when we try to reconstruct
the latent variables from this this is
our example this is the true well true
it's all done on simulations but you
know think of this as the truth through
the initial conditions through dark
matter and through its light and this is
how well we reconstructed it we
reconstruct the light very well the dark
matter final dark matter very well you
see we lose high frequency structure in
the initial collisions and that's
because of the structure formation okay
but again we don't care about this as I
said we care about the summary
statistics which is in this case the
power spectrum of these things and
here's an example I mean it's almost
down here here's an example where we try
to reconstruct this power spectrum we
here I'm showing divided by the truth
just to give an idea how are we doing
and we also have errors from the from
the Hessian that I'll show on the next
slide but the basic point to take away
point here is we are extracting
something which is around 1 with errors
as expected so we get unbiased results
from this procedure and you know we
would like to argue this at the smallest
possible errors one can achieve Hessian
here's I think this is a last slide
basically here I'm comparing now the
diagonal of the Hessian between these
two metals that I mentioned one is a
sampling of the modes and then add these
into this bootstrap for examples that I
mentioned and here is an example of how
well we do if you have one sample for
sample 32 samples you see there's a lot
of noise especially with one and the
noise is going down but the red line is
the one that I mentioned later which
were we try to do this alone
nation and the point is it's less noisy
it agrees with the other ones so we
think this is still the best method that
imagination and then just getting the
determinant with the simulation in this
case are the off diagonal terms are
essentially zero so we get just so the
Hessian is essentially diagonal is the
heading of the hyper parameters okay so
okay so that's a summary well doing an
anything marginalization in higher
dimensions is hard and standard linear
algebra metals definitely fail Socratic
approaches are more promising but they
are very different in their noise levels
MCMC is probably the worst we haven't
even tried because within this null
point but sampling followed by needy
gratings is better and finally a leading
marginalization of the hyper part of the
latent variables followed by sampling is
is the best and all these methods
benefit a lot if you try to reduce the
set of the sampling noise by using
sampling noise reduction methods like
you know same see numbers and stuff like
that okay and I think that's it positive
definite and they have to have nonzero
determinant yes good yeah no they're the
covariance matrices right but this
choice posted a no no no I'm not having
any noise no no no definitely they are
positive definite and definitely they
are
so there is a lot of work there I think
like four or five people here at least
hey there's based on randomized race
estimation so this my girl and do they
do they assume low rank yes and stuff
like that or do we need any of that
no we don't need low rank it goes it's
faster that might be 40 hours for
inverse problems and you have an inverse
problems thank you very much
[Applause]